like to talk to you figure out what's
going on
I'm Zach what's your name man
okay okay fair enough
so what's the problem today
like Carlisle area okay I know where
that's at that's where I went to
preschool
we're giving you your space we're not
trying to physically mess with you
so what are you doing on that side of
the railing what how come
we want to know what we need to do to
help you
I'm asking you outright what we what we
can do to help you and we're going to
try to make that work
I can tell you right now if you come on
this side nobody's tackling you
we're asking you what you want us to do
for you I called he didn't answer I'm
calling again he just might not
recognize the number
we're here to help you redeem yourself
if you fell off that bridge there's no
chance for that we don't want to see
that happen you're already three months
clean
three months clean you got your whole
life ahead of you
so how did you end up on that side what
what happened leading up to that I
wasn't here so I don't know
there's your grandpa uh that's your
grandpa
yeah it is
your grandpa right there
no no it's an officer's phone officers
here talk to him that's your grandpa
what what what what can me and your
grandpa do for you right now
then if we back up will you climb on
this side
I don't want you to think we're going to
try to rush you because we're not if if
we'll take some steps back you climb on
this side but we'll get you in a warm
car
we can fix your phone I'm setting this
by my phone so when you come over you
can get warm
as your boat
I don't want you to be
at the beginning of October we conducted
a hostage negotiation team training a
40-hour training class and officer Boone
was part of the class
all right thanks for coming over just
sit down grab the phone talk to your
brother being as I have done this for a
long time
and I'm a big proponent of this type of
training it was actually kind of a proud
moment that officer Boone was able to
talk to this guy and basically negotiate
him to the other side of the rail and
ultimately no harm was done and the
person got the help that he needed we're
going to give you a ride more than an
hour closer to 90 minutes to talk to
somebody talk to them into
not harming themselves that is
extraordinary it's a testament to the
training that we did and then as I
watched the video and some of the things
that he was saying to the person that
was in distress that was threatening to
jump it was exactly the things that we
had taught during the training